اقلت الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان الروس
عادوا الاعتماد خطط دفاعيه في باق موت
مرجحه توقف الهجوم على المدينه بسبب ما
سمته الاستنزاف الشديد للقوه الروسيه
واضافه ان الروس لجاوا الى خطه الدفاع
مشيره الى ان وضع القوات الروسيه في ضخمه
اسوا من ذلك بسبب التوترات بين وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ومجموعه
اما الروايه الروسيه لما يجري في بخمت
فنقلها موقع ريبار العسكري الذي اكد ان
القوات الروسيه تحاصر القوات الاوكرانيه
داخل المدينه من جهه الشمال والجنوب كما
سيطرت القوات الروسيه بشكل كامل على بلده
الواقعه شمال شرقي افديفيكا والتي تعد اخر
المعاقل التي كانت تخضع جزئيا لسيطره
القوات الاوكرانيه في الجناح الشمالي
الشرقي من مدينه افدي افكا
معنى من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي يعني هنالك الان
روايه روسيه وروايه اوكرانيه وروايه
بريطانيه لما يجري في باخموت من هذه
الروايات الثلاث هل يمكن استنتاج ما يجري
فعلا على الارض هناك
زين العابدين الروايه الانجليزيه هي خبر
يومي ينشر وكانه عمل استخباراتي ان الجيش
الروسي او حتى
خسرت حتى الان ما يقارب 30 الف مقاتل وهذا
رقم كبير جدا الهدف الروسي من بخموت اولا
اذا القدره للسيطره على بخموت اذا كلا
استنزاف وحدات النخبه
الاوكرانيه وجر الاحتياط الاوكراني لمنعه
من التحضر للهجوم المرتقب اما الهدف
الاوكراني هو
بقاء في المنطقه عدم اعطاء نصر سياسي
للرئيس بوتين وبالتالي استنزاف القوات
وجعلها ان تصل الى نقطه الذروه يعني كما
يقال بالانجليزيه زين العابدين الكلمنيشن
يعني انت لديك قوه كلما تقدمت تستنزف كي
تصل الى النقطه الذروه وعندها يبدا الدفاع
هذا امر يعتبر نصر لاوكرانيا اذا استطعت
ان تحافظ على الامل هذه هي الاهداف
المتناقضه مع بعضها ولكن الكل يتحضر
للمرحله القادمه طيب يعني اذا تحدثنا عن
النطاق الزمني هل هذا الوضع قابل
للاستمرار ولمده كم
ليس قابل للاستمرار الامر يتعلق بعده
عوامل زين العابدين يعني اليوم هل سيكون
هناك عسكر اضافي من الجيش الروسي عدا فاجن
لانها استنزفت للقتال في مخموت لاستكمال
استنزاف القوات الاوكرانيه هذا سبب اثنين
هل سيكون للقوات الاوكرانيه القرار
بالبقاء وما يدل على هذا الامر زياره
الرئيس زيلينسكي الى الجبهه في مكان ليس
بعيد عن بخموت لتشجيع العسكر ولكن دائما
كما قلت استنزاف روسي للقوات الاوكرانيه
وفتح معارك ثانيه كما تفضلت وقلت في
التقرير الدبكه هي مرحله تكون مخمود
الثانيه اما بالنسبه للاوكران فهذا الامر
يدل على ربح الوقت مقابل خساره المساحه
ولكن تحضيرا لما سياتي وهذا ما يقول عنه
بريكوجين ان القوات الاوكرانيه حضرت
تقريبا 80 الف مقاتل لهجوم عكسي قد يكون
احداه في مخموت شكرا جزيلا لك الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت